now we've all been told that getting
more oxygen into our cells is a really
really good thing so many diseases occur
because of this lack of oxygen whether
it's ischemia hypoxia whatever oxygen is
a good thing so today I'm going to
reveal a secret of how to increase
a valuable oxygen into your cells and so
you probably already know that sleeping
with the window open is going to help
increase oxygen maybe having more plants
in your room are going to give you more
oxygen okay you also probably know that
exercise will increase oxygen
specifically aerobic type exercise
that's the exercise that occurs maybe
when you're walking or a slight jog
being outside in nature will also give
you more oxygen right I recently did a
video and talked about methylene blue
can give you more oxygen to the cells
which is pretty interesting but
there is a very interesting secret about
oxygen that I'm going to share with you
right now that you may or may not know
about in order to increase the available
oxygen into the cells the release of
oxygen
out of your blood cells
there is a trigger there is this thing
that controls it and that is
CO2 that's right CO2
you see you probably thought CO2 was a
waste product and it's not needed you
know as you're breathing out all the CO2
and by the way when you're breathing out
an average person is probably breathing
out I don't know maybe 25 to 75 percent
oxygen so it's not all CO2 you're
breathing a lot of oxygen out too
because it's not being absorbed CO2 is
the key for the releasing of o2 and it's
called the Bora effect
Bohr effect CO2 tells the body to
release O2 and the way it works is that
CO2 increases the acidity makes things
more acid and then that loosens up the
oxygen so it can then be released take a
look at someone that is starving from
oxygen someone that is in a panic attack
right what are they doing
they are hyperventilating what happens
when you're hyperventilate is you're
trying to get a lot of oxygen right but
you're not getting a lot of CO2 what is
the most common recommendation when
someone is hyperventilating
breathe in a paper bag what does that do
that increases the CO2
allowing the oxygen then to go into the
cells so it might be a really good thing
to actually buy an oximeter you can
usually get them as a kind of a pulse
oximeter checks your pulse rate and
oxygen saturation and normally it should
be between 95 and 99 okay and we're
looking at how much oxygen is saturated
in your blood it's a pretty cool test
and it'll kind of give you a reading of
what's going on and so in this video I'm
going to show you how to increase the
oxygen and raise it up to 99 or even a
hundred and you can do this test on
yourself at first when you think about
it's very contourintuitive um we're
going to increase our CO2 to increase
our oxygen sounds weird but it really
works now a couple ways that you can
increase more CO2 breathe through your
nose versus breathing through your mouth
yeah that's right breathing through your
nose gives you more oxygen you would
think when you're sleeping that it would
restrict the air which it does and it
would restrict the oxygen but it doesn't
you'll have a much better sleep if you
breathe through your nose now this is
not all about just increasing your CO2
to 100 we need a balance of oxygen and
CO2 okay all we're trying to do is
balance it when we're under stress our
breathing changes and we no longer
balance the CO2 with the O2 we actually
are getting more oxygen and not enough
CO2 when we're under stress
and that's just probably
counterintuitive when you think about it
but the solution is to increase more CO2
and you can do that by simple breathing
as well like slowing down your breath
okay and balancing out the inhalation
with the exhalation there is one study
which I'll put down below that they
added more CO2 to this oxygen and they
gave this mixture of air
to these group of people who all had
hypoxia that's a condition where you
have lack of oxygen right and they all
increase their oxygen saturation which
is really interesting so you'll have to
prove this to yourself to see if it's
true but you will find it is true but by
increasing your CO2
uh you can greatly help stress anxiety
disorders panic attacks you can decrease
inflammation you can resolve many times
depression you can increase your
endurance with exercise you can decrease
symptoms of respiratory problems like
COPD or weaknesses within the lungs from
past injury you'll even be able to hold
your breath longer so how do we do this
well the first thing you need to do is
to do a test to determine something to
determine your carbon dioxide CO2
tolerance
how well your body is able to tolerate
CO2 and it's a very simple test okay and
I recommend you do it laying down on
your back on the floor okay all you need
is some type of a timing mechanism some
type of watch and because you're going
to just record the timing so to do this
you're going to nose breathe just only
breathe through your nose and you're
just going to inhale and exhale
three times with a timing of three
seconds so three seconds in
three seconds out
three seconds in three seconds out and
just do that three times now on the
fourth time you're going to expand your
lungs and breathe in as much as you can
so that fourth inhalation is a very
large inhalation now as you time this
next phase you're going to be timing the
slow continuous exhalation of air from
that inhalation and so you're not going
to want to hold your breath you're not
going to want to pause you just want to
slowly let the air out and you're going
to time it right and see how long that
takes but it has to be slow and
continuous and so you're going to record
the time until you run out of air okay
so now that you do that okay if it's 20
seconds or less
you're in poor condition as far as your
respiratory system your ability to
tolerate CO2
your stress is probably pretty bad you
probably have a low tolerance to stress
you probably have anxiety you probably
can't exercise for a long time as well
you probably run out of gas if you're
between 20 seconds and 40 seconds you're
in the average group okay
so not really great not terrible but
right in the middle if this exhalation
is between 40 seconds and 60 seconds
you're above average okay not really
good but you're definitely right in that
intermediate area you're definitely
above average now if that timing was
between 60 and 80 Seconds you are
considered Advanced okay you have good
stress tolerance you have good endurance
you're in pretty good shape you can
handle stress pretty good if you're over
80 Seconds you are in the category of
elite okay this is like an elite athlete
you have excellent stress responses
excellent cardiovascular great tolerance
to CO2
so that is the goal is to get you over
80. so what I want you to do right now
is do this test
and record your number in the comments
down below okay I want to read the
comments I want to see results I want to
see where you're at now the question is
how do we increase this tolerance to
ultimately increase your ability to get
oxygen in your cells because it's not
just about oxygen it's about the oxygen
availability to the cells which is
dependent on the CO2 and again we're
just trying to balance the CO2 with the
oxygen so a couple things to do okay
start doing nose breathing keep your
mouth shut when you sleep right and then
even to the day when you're driving
breathe through your nose another thing
you can do is start breathing uh with
emphasis on your diaphragm like just
focusing on breathing in through your
stomach
not to your chest okay and you're going
to slowly breathe in so you're pushing
out your stomach and then exhale slowly
so we're going to balance this
and I've talked about this technique to
help you sleep as well start focusing on
your sleep making sure that your
inhalation equals the exhalation and
that really helps you sleep and now you
know why because it increases more
oxygen because it increases more CO2 and
another thing you can do as a practice
routine is do box breathing it's called
four four four and four so you're
basically just going to breathe in for
four seconds you're going to then hold
your breath for four seconds and then
you're going to Exhale for four seconds
and then you're going to hold this
exhalation for four seconds and you're
just going to practice this okay uh
longer and longer and longer to see if
you can do it so that is going to help
you so nose breathing this box breathing
diaphragm breathing and also holding
your breath now of course you probably
want to do this supervise so that way if
you pass out it's not a problem but you
can just do this on a low level I don't
recommend practicing this while you're
driving I can just see this now
um someone
um passes out and they crash and then
they mention my name Dr Burke told me to
hold my breath while I was driving well
I'm telling you right now don't do this
while you're driving okay now there are
several other things you can do to
increase this CO2 tolerance and I'm
going to put a link down of a website
that will give you a lot more
information about this but I just wanted
to give you the concept some basic
things that you can start doing if you
get an oximeter now you can actually
have some feedback and you can do your
own testing on yourself to see what
works and then you can prove it to
yourself but anyway there's some great
information on this topic relating to
panic attacks and Asthma and I if you
haven't seen my video on that I put it
up right here check it out